[music playing]
GORDON RAMSAY (VOICEOVER):
I'm in Morocco, North Africa,
to discover the hidden
culinary secrets
of this incredible country.
I've always loved Moroccan
food because every bite
is steeped in history.
GORDON RAMSAY (VOICEOVER):
Over the centuries, the Arabs,
Spanish, Ottomans,
and French have all
left their mark on the cuisine
of the indigenous Berber
people.
My journey of discovery begins
in Fes, Northwest Morocco,
the country's culinary
capital, located on the edge
of the Middle Atlas Mountains.
[music playing]
The medina of Fes
is one of the oldest
walled cities in the world.
It feels like I've been
transported back in time.
Incredible and
beautiful and confusing
all at the same frickin' time.
Man.
So.
GORDON RAMSAY (VOICEOVER):
This place is like a labyrinth.
This is crazy.
GORDON RAMSAY (VOICEOVER):
There's over 9,000 alleyways,
and I think I've
been down every one.
The most confusing maze ever.
GORDON RAMSAY
(VOICEOVER): I'm supposed
to be meeting one of Morocco's
finest chefs, Najat Kaanache.
GORDON RAMSAY (VOICEOVER): But
finding our rendezvous point
is proving trickier
than I expected.
[chatter]
[bleep]
GORDON RAMSAY
(VOICEOVER): OK, I'm
pretty sure this is the spot.
Oh, my god!
How are you?
Finally.
[music playing]
GORDON RAMSAY (VOICEOVER):
Najat Kaanache
is one of a small band of
pioneering female chefs
changing the face
of Moroccan cuisine.
Voila.
GORDON RAMSAY (VOICEOVER): After
earning her stripes at a string
of Michelin-star establishments
across Europe and America,
her own restaurant in
the heart of the medina
is already gaining
quite a reputation.
The first thing
I thought about--
what would it be like to have
a restaurant here with all
this product on your doorstep?
Do you ever get lost out here?
You get lost.
Even if you live in
here, you get lost.
It is-- it is--
[both laugh]
So I'm not the only one.
I get lost, and I used to
walk in this medina barefoot,
so imagine.
In barefoot?
- Barefoot.
- It's so nice to met you.
Thank you.
Now I'm dying to get really
underneath this incredible
oasis.
Thank you very
much for coming here.
Can you lead the way,
'cause I'm useless.
- We go?
- OK.
- Can we go?
- (LAUGHING) Staight up?
Go on.
Thank you.
This place is crazy.
[music playing]
GORDON RAMSAY
(VOICEOVER): Najat tells
me that this has been a food
market since the 9th century.
NAJAT KAANACHE: This is
the flavors of Morocco.
GORDON RAMSAY: Wow.
NAJAT KAANACHE: Like here--
GORDON RAMSAY: Just the colors.
NAJAT KAANACHE:
Look at the colors.
GORDON RAMSAY: The colors.
NAJAT KAANACHE: Try this one.
GORDON RAMSAY: Thank you.
Mm.
That's delicious.
Chilies.
Mm.
You're too whitey for
hotness, I understand.
I'm too white for hotness?
Did you just say that to me?
I love chilies.
Let's focus on this, yeah?
Delicious.
Pretty good.
Thank you.
Amazing.
Look.
Look at the meat man.
You like to speak French, eh?
GORDON RAMSAY: And what is that?
NAJAT KAANACHE: This is the
[non-english],, Arab butter.
I need you to smell.
Oof!
Bloody hell.
GORDON RAMSAY: Yes.
I've made filo, but
that's not filo, no?
GORDON RAMSAY: OK, right.
OK.
It looks like my
grandma's curtains.
[laughs]
So is it flour and water?
You're hilarious.
This is water and flour.
GORDON RAMSAY:
That is beautiful.
I think you should
go inside and try.
Try that?
Yes.
And if I [bleep]?
Then I'm going to
correct you with those.
I'm allowed to do that today.
Right.
[laughs]
Will you tell her
I'm a cook in England?
'Cause she's looking at
me like I'm an idiot.
NAJAT KAANACHE: Venga, let's go.
[laughs]
GORDON RAMSAY: Ah!
You have to stretch
it without pressing.
Bravo.
NAJAT KAANACHE: Bravo, she says.
It's so wonderful
to see you do this.
Yes.
GORDON RAMSAY
(VOICEOVER): When Najat
finally stopped laughing at me,
I managed to finish my pastry.
NAJAT KAANACHE: Venga, stretch
it, and bring it in here, yeah?
Yeah.
Let's go.
Wow.
Mr. Gordon made.
Bravo.
[laughter]
Awesome.
Yeah, you like this more.
It's-- it's thin enough?
So now-- hello-- now,
you have to be careful.
When it cooks, you
gotta bring it up.
Gotcha.
Pick it up.
Oh, [bleep]!
Back on top a little bit.
[speaking arabic]
Thank you.
Bravo.
Thank you so much.
NAJAT KAANACHE: So easy.
E-- I wouldn't say easy.
Au revoir.
Merci beaucoup.
Man, it's a lot harder than
it looks, let me tell you.
I'm not very good at being
crap at doing something,
so I felt a little bit awkward.
That was difficult.
Well, not difficult. It's
a lot of practice, Chef.
GORDON RAMSAY (VOICEOVER):
Najat is a little firecracker.
That's how feisty she is.
Right now, I feel
like a fish out water.